TRUNK DOSSIER.
>> WE HAVE ONE OTHER LITTLE
PIECE HERE IN THE FBI AND WE
KNOW THAT ANDREW McCABE IS
UNDER INVESTIGATION.
NOW HE IS ALSO BEING
INVESTIGATED FOR LEAKS AS IT
RELATES TO GENERAL FLYNN.
AND THOSE LEAKS, WE KNEW FROM
THE GET-GO, WERE ILLEGAL,
BECAUSE -- IT SHOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN LEAKED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
>> THE INFORMATION WAS RELEASED
IN THE VAULT AND IT REVEALED
THAT THERE WAS AN INVESTIGATION
OF COMMENTS ALLEGEDLY MADE BY
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR ANDREW
McCABE ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND FLYNN.
WE DON'T KNOW ANYTHING MORE THAN
THAT, WE KNOW THAT THEY LIST
McCABE AS A WITNESS IN THE
INVESTIGATION, NOT A SUBJECT.
BUT IT'S A FIRST TIME WE HEARD
ANYTHING ABOUT THIS AND THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT THING.
THE SENATE CHIEF PLED GUILTY TO
LYING ABOUT HIS CONTACTS WITH
THE MEDIA'S OF THE FACET WAS
GOING ON AND STARTING TO BE
EXPOSED LITTLE BY LITTLE.
>> WE HAVE THE ENTIRE PUZZLE
FRAMED IN AND ARE FILLING IN THE
PIECES, IT'S PRETTY INCREDIBLE
WHAT HAPPENED.
CARTER, YOU ARE IN THE CENTER OF
THIS.
WE KNOW THAT FOR PFIZER JUDGES,
AND WE KNOW THAT CHRISTOPHER
STEELE WAS ON STANDBY.
NOW YOU HAVEN'T ROD ROSENSTEIN
AND HE'S REFUSING TO TESTIFY
UNDER OATH.
WE CAN'T GET GLENN SIMPSON TO
TESTIFY UNDER OATH, WAY AND WE
CAN'T GET THE THREE OH TWOS AND
FINDS OUT APPLICATIONS THAT WERE
ALL SUBPOENAED AND SUPPOSED TO
BE COMING OUT.
YOU ARE ASSUMING THE DNC, AND
WHO ELSE?
>> PERKINS COOLEY AND A FEW OF
THEIR PARTNERS.
>> WELL, I HAVE TO IMAGINE, YOU
ARE GOING TO BE A REALLY WEALTHY
GUY.
BECAUSE WHAT THEY DID TO YOU,
ALL YOUR FOURTH AMENDMENT
PROTECTIONS WERE STOMPED ON.
THIS ISN'T POLITICAL.
>> IT GOES BEYOND ANY DAMAGES OR
ANY FINANCIAL ASPECTS.
THERE HAVE BEEN SO MANY LIES AS
YOU ARE ALLUDING TO AND YOU LOOK
AT THE DAMAGE IT DID TO OUR
DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM AND
INSTITUTIONS OF GOVERNMENT BACK
IN 2016.
I'M JUST TRYING TO GET SOME
JUSTICE IN TERMS OF GETTING SOME
DISCLOSURE.
IF YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE PRIOR
DODGY DOSSIER CASES, LIKE
MR. GOODBAR AS, HE HAD
INFORMATION OUT THERE IN THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
AND HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
HAVE BEEN FACING A LOT OF THINGS
ON IN TERMS OF THEIR
INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: YOU ALSO HELP YOUR
GOVERNMENT, YOU WOULD DEBRIEF
AFTER TRAVELING ABROAD FREELY
WITH THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY,
FBI, CIA.
AND THEY HAVEN'T INDICTED YOU.
REALLY QUICK AND THE LAST THREE
SECONDS WE HAVE COME UP WHAT'S
NEXT HERE AND WHERE ARE THESE
THE CLASSIFICATIONS, AND WHERE
ARE THE UNREDACTED MATERIALS,
WHEN ARE THEY COMING?
>> I THINK THEY ARE BEING SWELL
LOCKED AGAIN AND I THINK IT'S
FRUSTRATING FOR THOSE WHO WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THE TRUTH.
I THINK YOU ARE NOT GOING TO SEE